first of all I've seen the first three
episodes I thought they were fantastic I
can't wait to finish the season before
we go go into that I just have to
address one thing you have a family
member that was just cast as Catwoman
have you guys already been joking around
about being in the same universe like
both in DC and all that we have been
joking around about I think it's just
more of just being super proud of her I
mean she's so talented and you know
we're both and DC didn't should be good
to me and and uh excited for her you
know I mean it's just it's fun and just
my kid are you know her her brother and
sister are gonna be there and being that
whole world and just be able to watch
her and it's just the trips I had my
kids on Justice League and Aquaman and
watching me badass I'm great I'm a
hundred percent sure like yes I loved
the gas tank well now let's jump into
why I get to talk to you guys today um
so one of the things about this is I was
there was a lot of talk when the show
was first coming out that all the Apple
shows were gonna be like really PG and
really safe and like whatever and I
watched the first three episodes I'm
like oh no this is some real [ __ ] in it
like yeah I know I know they took it all
the little watermelon none of the others
are just famille noggin and they kept
him in I was shocked
listen I watched episode three last
night and again I'm gonna pardon the
language there was a point in Episode
three where I said holy [ __ ] yeah like I
was yeah I loved it so talk a little bit
about actually I don't want to make you
guys talk about episode three I want to
talk about the world-building because it
is really really so well done it feels
fully developed three-dimensional I just
like all the characters on screen can
you sort of talk about the the
world-building of the show francis Apple
I mean all our producers everyone killed
it because I mean walking into it we
can't I mean we get hired we come into
it and it's unbelievable I think every
department has to know about every
department they all have to link up to
each other you know props need to know
about weapons and weapons even know
about fights
the sets are involved
everyone had these completely in tune
Daniel because it all has to support the
blind community right the last to
support the blind world so who everyone
that was before us really coming in and
made all jobs a hell of a lot easier
than the support of us having a massive
boot camp where I've never had to
experience that was a group acting
therapy slash movement slash you know
sleep shades and yeah since I think the
show country workouts you know I mean
they it was something I've never
experienced before humbling because you
know in my own you get just to a process
of like just dealing with this isn't my
process to discovering wow this is
really learning a lot connecting on
another level that I've never done with
other cast members and that's it's just
really moving at the pinnacle of more of
my career is and never done work like
that before
yeah it's a it means everything to you I
think I think the stuff that we did
there in that and that month or so we
had just to prep and always exercises in
moments we created we were creating
memories and stuff that you know century
memories between like us and the family
and stuff and I think that's to be able
to do that on show to be able to be
given the time and the people and the
resources to do that it's just amazing
and you know I think that's what you'll
see that you feel that in the show
yeah the back I mean he'd seen extras
cuz they were just in our world always
constantly with us yep pretty much
better than I was and it's just
respectfully disagree on this well
there's a lot of guys I mean dude Navid
is unbelievable I know beauty is double
work like we had a whip masters and we
just wanted so many things but you're
doing it with your background so I'm
standing next to you know a part of our
tribe that they're just they're not just
walking around the space we everyone has
a job and it's it's just you bit you're
talking about world building that's it
yeah yeah we're building it with the
whole community yeah how much did you
guys know when you're doing a show like
this which could run for multiple
seasons how much did you sort of ask
where is this all going to go or you
know I mean like or how much you know
like just trusting and Steven Knight and
Francis Lawrence
we had to do a lot of trusting and I
mean I definitely did um yeah we knew
certain things and then certain things
changed yeah I don't know how what to
say about that relief because it's you
know without going into it I don't
really don't want to know us no no of
course like you know like you want to
hope that you have a multi-season or let
you know that I definitely that getting
yeah yeah we knew or was going and when
I talked to Steven I was extremely
excited that phone call was hands down
when the best one cuz I've ever had
because he just gave all the spoilers of
where we're going and what the whole
world is gonna be and so knowing that
knowing what I know and you don't know
is and just to go into his mind his was
so full of like it's just amazing so
that was great
one of the things that I took away from
your character in this is that the your
character has a lot of heart and it's
very three-dimensional it's not just
some badass and did that like appeal I
mean that had to appeal to you as why
you wanted to do it yeah I just think
there's a lot of things I've done in my
career that may mimic never look like
this because of you know covered in fur
with much of Blades fighting battle
scenes and I just never been able to do
the whole father aspect of it and the
sensitivity that you get with plenty
baba Voss compared to the other ones
I've done not having vision you're gonna
be hiding in other senses and so just
being the ultimate lawyer of having all
these sentence senses heightened I never
played anything like that before or dad
so it was amazing
we're 20 years older yeah yeah like my
greys
listen man I I really can't wait to
watch the rest of the season like I mean
that sincerely
I apologize I have another question for
Jason it's just out further I know
there's Jesus the Collider people and
myself are very curious were all
extremely excited for doom oh me too
stream Li Danny - Danny is a genius -
Denny is a genius listen so it's Francis
but I'm like [ __ ] love these two I'm
Barry that's been a goddamn great year
for me but uh Denny it's gonna be
unbelievable what do you want to know
about doing nothing that what can you
tell people about it that
will not get you in trouble and do you
know when you're filming Aquaman to IMAP
ahead to probably be I mean definitely
your plus away I don't have a set date
on that
unfortunately what can I say about tune
he's done he's a genius and the cast is
pretty amazing
I've never seen well I can't wait to
tell you about stuff
Javier's a badass right I want to know
so much but I don't want to get you yeah
I don't know either yet but I'm very
very excited for all of it thank you
dear